Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. You Frenchmen, not a contender with having robbed us of everything we held dear, have also corrupted our character. The present condition of my country, and my powerlessness to change it, are additional reasons for me to leave a land where I am obliged by duty to praise men whom I ought by virtue to hate. When I arrive in my country, how am I to act and what am I to do? When the mother country has ceased to exist, a good citizen should die. If I had to destroy but one man in order to deliver my fellow countrymen, I would start at once. I would plunge the avenging dagger up to the hilt in the breast of the tyrant. teenage subject of suicide. And Napoleone Bonaparte is, of course, better known as Napoleon
Bonaparte. And we are looking at the origins of this titanic figure of French history. But the extraordinary thing is that, of course, he wasn't really French at all, was he? As that brilliant impression has conveyed to the listener. Hello, everybody, if you're still listening. Tom, I think that's one of the most extraordinary impressions you've ever done. Thank you. I think we'll just gloss over the accent completely because we could be talking for hours.
But it's conveying an important point, isn't it? It is. Well, he starts, you Frenchmen, you've robbed us of everything we held dear. You've corrupted our character. And he talks about my country and the country he's talking about in that beautiful Italian accent. Well, it's not Italian, is it? It's Corsican because the country he's talking about in that beautiful Italian accent. Well, it's not Italian, is it?
It's Corsican because the country is Corsica. Yeah. It's a Ligurian dialect, which I hope the listeners picked up on. Yeah. Genoese listeners. So Napoleon, as you say, a superhuman historical figure. I suppose eclipsed in the public mind now by the dictators of the 20th century, but for so long, he was the paradigmatic great man of history, wasn't he,
Napoleon? For Carlyle. The most titanic figure in 19th century history. Definitely. Even though he's basically off the scene by 1815. And sort of overshadows all those paintings, all those novels, Stendhal Stendhal's Le Rouge et le Noir, Tolstoy War and Peace. Napoleon is the cultural figure par excellence of the 19th century, I suppose. Which is why Ridley Scott is making a film about him. And of course, we're not in any way jumping on that bandwagon. We would never do that. I mean, I think we've been very conscious of the fact that we haven't really done much about Napoleon on the rest of history. We've done an episode on his venture to Egypt, and we've done some episodes on the Battle of Trafalgar, won by his great British counterpart, I suppose, Nelson.
But considering Napoleon's outsized influence on modern Western history, he's in a neglected area. So we're going to try and make amends today today and we're going to be looking specifically at his origins aren't we yeah so kind of young napoleon because eventually we'll make our way through all napoleon's life but we'll start this week by just looking at the young napoleon as we once looked at uh young churchill and i guess actually tom that reading that you started with which no doubt so many listeners really enjoyed i'm sure they did the important thing about that is the Corsican-ness. The Corsican-ness, I have to confess, like everybody, I kind of knew he was Corsican, but never really thought about how significant it was.
It had never occurred to me until doing the reading for these podcasts, how colossally important it is that he is not French. Well, there you see, Dominic, I have the advantage of you. I've been to Corsica and I've visited his family house in Ajaccio. Right. Yeah. And I've seen for myself the proud and rugged independence of Corsican people as manifested in the bullet holes that riddle any sign in French on that fair island. Would it be fair to say, Tom, Corsica, land of contrasts? It's not really a land of contrasts.
I mean, it's just one thing. It's just one faintly terrifying place. And the hostility to France is still very much there. I mean, so my friend, Jamie Muir, son of Frank Muir, the great comedian, he has a family house out there that Frank Muir got. So that's why I went and stayed there. And he was telling me the extraordinary fact that the French were planning to test their He has a family house out there that Frank Lear got, so that's why I went and stayed there. He was telling me the extraordinary fact that the French were planning to test their nuclear
program, their atom bombs, in the 1950s on Corsica. Oh my word. You can kind of understand why there's a certain freder. That's probably not the word. No, there'd be some Italian word. Whatever it is in Genoese dialect. Let's talk a bit about Corsica first to put Napoleon in context. So 18th century Corsica.
It's a mountainous island, isn't it? Big island, very mountainous. Poor, but proud. Poor, but proud. Very good. Rugged, independent, poor, and proud. That's how we like our islands. Yes.
And it's kind of pre-feudal, isn't it? So most people don't own anything um they live on kind of chestnuts and cheese acorns yeah it's owned by the republic of genoa but the genoese only are really based on the coast and they don't really go into the interior much and most of the people as you said speak this kind of ligurianian dialect. And when Napoleon's father, so his father is called Carlo Maria Buonaparte, when he was born in 1746, it was still technically Genoese, but the Corsicans had started rising up
and having rebellions and stuff, hadn't they? They have. And the guy who is the great laureate of this for the rest of Europe is James Boswell, the biographer of Samuel Johnson, who refers to them as a brave and free people. And he goes there and ever after he goes around, when he goes to balls and things in London, he's always wearing Corsican dress and he's known as Corsican Boswell. What do Corsicans wear? A proud and rugged and independent and vendetta
loving kind of costume. Right. I can imagine a beret of some kind. Yeah, a pistol slipped into a sash, perhaps. Extremely large trousers, I would imagine. But this is the vibe that's coming off. Very much. For lovers of freedom and liberty and all this kind of stuff in the 18th century, Corsica seems like a place that they can fixate on. It's kind of a bit like Venezuela for people in labor under Jeremy Corbyn. It's a place where you
project your fantasies and your political ideals onto, I think. Yeah, it's the Cuba, isn't it? I suppose is the parallel. And there's a guy who's the Che Guevara or the Fidel Castro, who's called Pasquale Paoli. Who Boswell loves and who he gets ultimately sent into exile after the French exit, goes to London and Boswell is always taking him off to parties and kind of showing off with him. I had never realized how much he is a model for Napoleon because he called himself the general of the nation. He had a dream of this kind of new, modern Corsican state with a constitution, with a university, with all kinds of public institutions. That's very enlightenment. It's that combination of nationalism and enlightenment thinking and the slight hint of the father of the nation. That's very Napoleonic, actually, isn't it? And that's
in the 1750s. I mean, interesting. What isn't Napoleonic is that Pasquale comes to be a great admirer of the British constitution, the kind of the mixed constitution as it's known in the 18th century. And it's a reminder that before the French revolution, there was this kind of anglomanie, this obsession with the British example of constitutionalism, which of course, the French Revolution and then Napoleon will set themselves very much against. So Corsica is a kind of cockpit for that ideological rivalry, which powers the Anglo-French rivalry through the Napoleonic Wars. So anyway, Carlo, Carlo Buonaparte is a massive fan of this guy, Pasquale Paoli.
And he sort of teams up with him at various points. Carlo marries this very beautiful heiress called Letizia Ramolino, who is 14 years old at the time. I think that gives you an indication of the proud and rugged approach to romance. She's a very impressive woman. And Napoleon always stays absolutely devoted to her, doesn't he? Yeah. He always says that she is the woman who made him what he was. Absolutely.
And she has hundreds of children, doesn't she? There's about, how many of them are there? There's about 10 of them or 11 of them. And they all end up kind of kings and whatever. They do, which no one could have predicted at the time. So they are married in the late 1764, actually. They're married in 1764. They have their first son, Joseph, in 1768.
And in 1768, that's an important year because that is the year that the Genoese have been trying to impose order on Corsica. They basically give up. They owe France loads of money, and they say to the French, actually, just have Corsica. We're sick of Corsica. They basically give up. They owe France loads of money. And they say to the French, actually, just have Corsica. We're sick of Corsica. It's a flipping pain. You have Corsica. So the French move in in 1768. Pasquale Paoli is not happy about this, issues a call to arms. He basically gets kicked out and goes off to England. And one of his supporters is Carlo, and he's sort of charging about hither and thither.
And it's in the middle of all this turmoil that his wife, who is pregnant with her second son, they almost get swept away by a torrent or something, some very Greek myth style story. It's very Corsican. And the 15th of August, 1769, she has this baby who they christen Napoleone. It was a not uncommon name in Corsica. Sometimes it was spelt Nabuleone or Lapuleone. I think Lapuleone is a terrible name for an early 19th century master of Europe. Domineering master of Europe.
No, you couldn't do that. But what Carlo does that is really important is once the French have come in he accommodates himself to the French doesn't he he goes off and gets basically a fake title a nobility title that allows him to become a lawyer but also of course Dominic in the long run will enable his sons to benefit from the kind of education that only the nobles can have exactly actually I said 11 children I've just looked at my notes it's 13 children wow Three of them died young, two in childbirth, so loads of them. So he sucks up to the French
and Napoleone, the second son, he grows up in this occupied Corsica, effectively. He doesn't go to school, Tom? I thought he did.
Well, his mother said later that she'd sent him to lessons at a girls' school and Napoleon, obviously, was keen to downplay this. But there's some story at school that they have to role play the Romans and the Carthaginians. Is that not later in France, though? Or is that in Corsica? Oh, was it?
I think it must be later in France. Oh, okay. Oh, maybe. Because apparently some priest... No, because it's Joseph who describes and says it was at their first school in Corsica. So I don't know. I mean, clearly there are lots of different different stories that are swirling around depending which biography you read you'll have different credence placed on different anecdotes so he refuses to sit under to play the carthaginian role because he wants to play the
roman one oh there must be back projection there because the french will come to identify themselves with the romans and they will identify the the British with the Carthaginians. So probably not a true story, but I don't know. And I think it is clear when you read all the various accounts that there are multiple, multiple stories, many of which have kind of mythic qualities. So what we do know about him is he's growing up in Ajaccio. He's part of this huge family.
It's extremely poor. They're not a particularly poor family. They have aspirations. They're an aspirational kind of upwardly mobile family. But it is generally a violent, scratchy kind of upbringing, isn't it? he would have seen French mobile columns burning the countryside, slaughtering the flocks of rebels. He would have seen the corpses of rebels hung on the public highway as a warning to those who defied the imposition of French rule. And he himself seems to, I mean, the one thing that all the accounts of Napoleon as a little boy say is that he's extremely aggressive and quarrelsome and also that he liked reading tom i think that's the one thing that's kind of attractive about him yes he's a massive autodidact isn't he definitely he is yeah and very obsessed by ancient history he loves reading about the romans and the greeks always always reading about that so in a way very much like me is that like you tom you grew up in the Badlands of Wiltshire
and another poor, backward, rural community. Yeah, poor but proud. Yeah. So Napoleon, we said he was born in 1769. In 1778, when he is nine years old, his father Carlo decides he really wants him to go to a military academy. So the military academy is an obvious engine for
social mobility. You'll join the army and you'll move upwards. Yeah. But also to learn French, which at this point he barely speaks. And the amazing thing is that when he goes away to join this military academy, he's then away from Corsica for eight years. Yeah. So January 1779, his father has got permission for him to go to academy in France, but he starts off going to a school in Autun to learn French before he can embark on this military career. And despite the fact that he's presumably having this fairly intensive course, he never, ever learns to speak French particularly well.
I read from Adam Zamoyski, his grammar and use of words remain poor. His accent is always a very strong Corsican accent. His handwriting never developed beyond an ugly scrawl. It's a real surprise to me, actually, because the depictions of him that you have are always, you can imagine him as a Frenchman, and he's always portrayed as a Frenchman. But the idea of him as an outsider who's actually always speaking to other Frenchmen in this very thick Corsican accent, it sort of changes your view of him, I think, a bit, doesn't it?
Because the emphasis on him as an outsider is something that's often missing, I would say, from A Count's Anabolium. Yeah. Well, I think also that, as listeners will see from this episode, that tension between the Corsican, which focuses the memories of his earliest years, and then this eight-year period of education, which begins with him having to do a kind of crammer course in French. Yeah. This is a struggle that won't ultimately be resolved until the end of episode two. No, because at this point, he definitely identifies himself as a corsican he goes to these a succession of military academies i mean we could be all here for weeks going through military academy after military academy but they're all very austere aren't they they're all run on almost
slightly monastic lines where you kind of get up literally because the teachers are friars and monks yeah and when we call them military academies, that's actually slightly misleading because you sort of think they're just studying guns and stuff, but actually they're not. They're spending all their time... They're studying ancient history.
Yeah. But also maths, because he turns out to be brilliant at maths, doesn't he? He is. He is, which never endears people to me, actually, if I'm honest. But this is important
because a mastery of maths leads you into the artillery yeah which is where napoleon will ultimately go to begin with he wants to join the navy which is yeah quite something could he have been on the deck of whatever it was instead of villeneuve facing nelson i mean his education is full of kind of ironies like that so andrew robertson his biography has the tremendous detail that on the very last pages of his school exercise book, following a long list of British imperial possessions, he noted, Yeah, I saw that. It's that little island of St. Helena that Napoleon will end up on. The list of classical authors that he read is extraordinary. Caesar, Cicero, Suetonius, Tacitus.
He read Erasmus. Plutarch was his great favourite. And Plutarch, of course, is a titanic figure in the 18th century because Plutarch writes this idea of great lives, great people who shape history. That clearly entered into Napoleon's soul. But there's a kind of romance to him as well because he loves the fake kind of Gaelic poet,ian did you see that tom i did yeah of course everyone
everyone did in the 18th century completely made up fingal isn't it yes completely made up so he's um he's a he's a blend of kind of proto-romantic nationalistic and obviously enlightenment thinking because he's also reading new voltaires and Rousseau's and all these kinds of things. So he goes from one academy to the other. By 1784, he's at the École Militaire. Oh, Dominic, we mustn't forget to mention the snowball fight, which is so- Not true. Not true, but important because it feeds massively into the myth. So it's one of the key scenes in Abel Gance's great film about Napoleon, black and white film. And it kind of goes on for about 20 minutes. And according to
the legend, Napoleon seizes control of this snowball fight. It goes on for two weeks. He ranges his snowball fighters into platoons and divisions and they storm hills and things like this. And obviously it's completely made up, but it is a kind of interesting example of the, again, of the way in which Napoleon's future career is back projected into his education and the kind of the mythology that grows up around his childhood. Yeah, I think that's absolutely right. So much of, it's hard to discern the true Napoleon in some ways because so many of the sources are written later. And as you say, are kind of inventing this heroic part of him. I mean, the one thing we know about him as a boy,
I mean, what does he know? He's a teenager, 15, 16 or so. One of his contemporaries said later that he was uncommunicative, fond of solitude, capricious, arrogant, and extremely self-centered. Much of the time, he appeared to be in a world of his own, pacing up and down, lost in thought, gesticulating or laughing to himself. That's very like me as a teenager. Really?
I didn't become dictator of Europe. No, you didn't. You became. What did you become? I took an alternative. I became a podcaster, Dominic. One of Britain's leading podcasters, Tom. That's how I describe you.
Yeah. Worn off. Anyway, his big cause, though, is Corsica. He's how I describe you. Worn off, anyway. His big cause, though, is Corsica. He's obsessed with Corsica, and clearly this is brought out by being in France. All his biographers say he's almost certainly bullied
at school by the other boys because of his Corsican accent, because he's quite short. He's sallow. His skin is darker. He doesn't speak good French. All of this stuff. He's a loner by nature and a reader and just a difficult kind of abrasive person. Spiky. I mean, I suppose a boy in that situation, you've got two options, haven't you? Either you jettison your Corsican heritage completely and you absolutely erase all sense of not being French,
or you accentuate your Corsican-ness. You embrace what is making you bullied. And he obviously goes for the second option. Yes, he does. I mean, he's good. He's a good student, isn't he? He does well. He proceeds through the different academies. In 1785, he sits the exam for the artillery. There are 58 candidates and he comes 42nd, which sounds rubbish. But actually, almost all the other candidates had done years more preparation than him. So it's a pretty good result for somebody who hasn't done as much prep and isn't even French. And he's posted second lieutenant to a prestigious regiment, the regiment of La Faire,
which is stationed in Valence, kind of in the sort of southwest central France. And actually, for somebody who's so disputatious and difficult, he's actually got on pretty well. He's a great reader. He's very serious. He's not set for a glittering career, but he's set for a decent career as long as he stays French, because there's still a possibility of him being drawn, sucked into the world of Corsican nationalism. His father has died, and Pasquale Paoli, who's still hanging around in London talking to Boswell and drawing up plans for Corsican universities.
Brushing his enormous moustaches. Exactly. He's still out there, and Napoleon worships him. One of his biographers says he turns Pauli into this sort of invented father figure. And actually his first essay that survives is a history of Corsica. He's always writing histories of Corsica, essays about Corsica, Gothic novels set in Corsica, all these kind of weird things. I mean, I think to anyone who's been a history-obsessed adolescent boy, he's not an entirely unrecognisable type. Very moody, very kind of intellectually arrogant.
Tom, are you describing yourself or are you describing... No, well, I just kind of, you know, anyone listening who has been an adolescent boy would find perhaps elements of Napoleon not entirely unrecognisable. And that is simply to say that I don't think there's anything particularly about him that perhaps elements of Napoleon not entirely unrecognizable. And that is simply to say that I don't think there's anything particularly about him at this point that marks him out as, you know, a man of destiny or anything.
No, no, no. I agree with you about that. If he was around now, he would be putting up earnest conversations on YouTube. You know, he'd be on TikTok, all that kind of stuff. But you know what, Tom?
Very moody and... He's all that's worst stuff. Very moody. He's all that's worst about teenagers. I think he is. Thinking about the difference in him and the other great character that we've done, his youth in great detail, which is Churchill. Churchill was ridiculous as a teenager going around saying, I will save the empire and all that sort of stuff. But Churchill was funny and he was a bullion. And you could imagine he was a great laugh and he was very likable all napoleon school contemporaries say of him he was actually awful he was really dislikable he was very had no sense of humor you know he's always yeah or having fights with people
and just a difficult why does no one recognize my genius yeah very much that kind of thing as a teenager he started writing Gothic novels. Yeah, of course he did. I mean, of course. That's exactly what you'd expect. He wrote a book called Le Comte d'Essex. Yeah. A book about Andrew Roberts. I couldn't help but think about your vampire novels, Tom,
because Andrew Roberts quotes a bit of it. The fingers of the countess sank into gaping wounds. Her fingers dripped with blood. She cried out, hid her face, but looking up could see nothing. Terrified, trembling, aghast, cut to the very quick by these terrible forebodings, the countess got into a carriage
and arrived at the tower. Let he who has never written a gothic melodrama in his youth cast the first stone, Dominic. However, I do think we're being a little bit unfair though, because as I say, he's also tremendously good at maths. That's worse. No, it isn't, because it gets him his posting in the artillery regiment, and this is actually quite a big deal. So we shouldn't ignore the fact that he does have the prospect of a pretty
glittering career ahead of him. I mean, it's not kind of astounding, but relative to what he could have ended up doing, it's pretty impressive. Agreed. So we should put that on the record. So he's there. We get to the late 1780s. France has run into terrible financial trouble, as we've discussed when we did the podcast about the Seven Years' War and indeed about the American Revolution. France has exhausted its finances, both through mismanagement and massive structural problems, but through a succession of wars, this great competition with Britain for mastery of the oceans, for mastery of the Americas, and so on and so forth.
And Napoleon, he's sitting around in his regiment in Valence, and actually his great dream is to write a history of Corsica. And that's what he's doing. While the French political body politic is being kind of roiled by all these ructions, Louis XVI recalls the Estates General, France's sort of stupid comparison, but France's equivalent of parliament, to try and sort out its financial woes. Napoleon is delighted at that because he thinks a liberalization of the French constitution will give more autonomy to Corsica. But also I think he has decided that he's a Republican already, hasn't he? Yes, he is. Because he's been reading Rousseau and he's been reading lots of
enlightenment stuff. Your comparison with him and modern teenagers on youtube or tiktok you know he has imbibed as people do now as people do at any point in history he has imbibed all the fashionable ideas of the of the day yeah and you know he's he's sort of pumped up with all this stuff um he's very he's always writing these things about um liberty and stuff but interestingly he's still at this point 1789 he sees the French as the villains. So he writes to Pasquale Paoli, who's in London. And he says, this is 1789. And he says, I'm very keen to write a history of Corsica. And in his letter, he says, I was born as our fatherland was perishing. My eyes opened to the odious sight of 30,000 Frenchmen who had been
vomited onto our shores, drowning the throne of liberty in rivers of blood. Very kind of teenage prose, but so interesting that at this late stage, he still sees the French as the oppressors and Corsica as his kind of motherland and Corsica as his future. He does, but at the same time, when the Bastille is stormed in July 1789, I mean, he's still engaged in French politics, isn't he? Because I think he's the only artillery graduate of his year who actually supports what's going on. And when lots of his contemporaries in the artillery start fleeing, he doesn't actually flee. I mean, he does go back to Corsica, but he's not going into exile.
So I think there is a sense in which he can feel the excitement of this incipient revolution and isn't completely abandoning it, but is seeing it as a way... I mean, I suppose the idea of liberty and fraternity is something that he can apply to Corsica. And so the question, I suppose, for Napoleon is, can you square these circles? Can you be simultaneously a Frenchman who supports the revolution and a nationalist in Corsica? And this is the huge issue that will determine the course of his life in the long run. And we should return to that issue, Tom, after the break. We shall. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman.
And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets,
head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestis rest is entertainment.com that's the rest is entertainment.com hello welcome back to the rest is history we're looking at the young napoleon and dominic in the first half we were looking at his various kind of teenage boy attitudes his occasional feelings of self-pity, his identification with all kinds of romantic causes, his growing enthusiasm for the revolution, his sense of being a Corsican, and whether that might lead him into overt anti-French nationalism. So, a great cauldron, Dominic, a cauldron of emotions and thoughts. But of course, teenage boys, one other thing that very often they are interested in is girls.
Yes. So what's going on down there, as it were? Down there. Thank you, Tom. He is not a man for the ladies, actually, it's fair to say. So you can well imagine that a lot of the blokes in these military academies are kind of sneaking out and having assignations and things like that napoleon everybody says about him when they do go to sort of salons and things like that he cuts a very unattractive figure but he's kind of scrawny and scruffy isn't he he's very scruffy his sort of hair is like lank and kind of hanging down. His olive skin,
where they are paler, he has a thick accent. And his first encounter, which I know you greatly enjoyed reading about, is a very strange and unprepossessing one, isn't it? 1787, I think. Yeah. So he's in Paris. He goes to see a play and he comes out and he describes himself in kind of classic tones. My soul, agitated by the vigorous sentiments natural to it, made me bear the cold with indifference. But when my imagination cooled, I began to feel the rigors of the season and made for the arcades. And arcades is where prostitutes are hanging out. And he meets with a young girl and he's obviously wants to do what a chap wants to do with a prostitute, I guess. But also he feels inhibited
about it, partly, I guess, because of nerves, but also because he has this whole Rousseau attitude, la nouvelle Eloise of high-minded. It's all about emotion and the mingling of souls and all this stuff. So there's a lot of kind of Rousseau-ish type conversation with this poor girl who clearly doesn't want all this kind of conversation. And yeah, it's all kind of weird. And he writes it up in a kind of slightly odd way. He does. He writes like an essay about it. And he admits that basically he's talking to her for ages, just wittering on about abstract nouns. And she's basically said, come on, let's crack on. She does. She says to him, listen, we could warm ourselves and you can satisfy your fancy. And he goes back.
And in this whole description that he writes, he doesn't describe at all what happens after they go back. So there's a kind of, as biographers say, there was always a kind of prudishness, priggishness, Puritanism to him. I think it's the kind of 18th century cult of the of the sentiment isn't it i suppose so yeah james boswell never had these kinds of problems no he didn't but i mean i imagine there is a kind of awkwardness a gaucheness that he dresses up in these fine fine sounding enlightenment tones but yeah again he's not the kind of commanding titanic figure oh no that's destiny who you might think at this point. He's still very kind of shy, very awkward, insecure, I guess you'd say.
Yeah, which I mean, we can be lenient, Tom, given that he is an outsider. He's a teenager. You don't have to judge him too harshly for all those kinds of things. Anyway, back to the revolution. I mean, he doesn't know it's going to be the French Revolution, I guess. We're only the stormy, the Bastille. Lots of his fellow officers, as you say, they scram. They're horrified. Yeah, they're mutiny and stuff. Even at this early stage, it's so interesting that his first instinct is to go back to Corsica. And he returns to Ajaccio at
the end of September 1789. And he finds, and this will be a theme throughout the rest of this episode, he finds Corsica basically in total and utter chaos. Because French rule has never been entirely accepted by all the Corsicans, has it? And some of the Corsicans are sending, there's a man called, with the unfortunate name of Butafocco. Yes. I wondered whether you would be mentioning him. So Matteo Butafoco, he's the representative of the nobility, and he is sent off to France to say, can we have a bit more self-rule? Other people want greater integration into France. But meanwhile, I mean, that's just the sort of the surface political stuff.
And underneath it, there's all these different clans and factions kind of fighting for control of the island. His brother, Joseph, who is on Corsica, has helped set up a patriotic committee, which he's the secretary. Napoleon himself goes around handing out tricolor cockades. You see, which is fascinating, isn't it? Because that is, of course, revolutionary. He's not at this point an overt nationalist, and yet clearly he's doing it for nationalist reasons. Yeah. And I think it would be a mistake to kind of impose too much a sense that he has clear thoughts on this. Yeah, I think that's right.
I suspect that it's his kind of emotions that are leading him. I mean, a bit like when he's meeting with the prostitute and he's disguising confusion beneath the show of fine language. I imagine he's doing the same with this really. Absolutely right. That impulse is controlling him at this point. The other thing about France is that I think he defines France at different times in different ways. Sometimes he sees France as the- Colonial power.
The colonial power that is oppressing Corsica. But other times he obviously thinks of France as almost like a universal idea. Well, this is the great thing, isn't it, of the revolution, is that the ideals of the revolution are framed as being universal and therefore applicable not just to metropolitan France, but to Corsica as well. So it's interesting that as he's giving out these tricolor cockades, the colours, the red, white, and blue of France. He is also still writing his Corsican history book, Tom, which he claims that the Corsicans are the heirs of the Romans. And he also writes this mad thing. He writes, this is a short story he wrote. He writes a short story about an old man in Corsica who it's revealed his mother, the old man's mother was raped and
murdered by French soldiers. And the old man in a sort of death wish sort of style scenario, takes revenge on every Frenchman he meets and boards a ship and kills everybody on the French ship, including the cabin boy. Yeah. We dragged their bodies to our altar and there burned them all. The new incense seemed to please the deity. God. Yeah.
Which, of course, again again is simultaneously very you know corsican vendetta all that kind of stuff but is also looking forward to the terror yeah and the idea of blood and violence as being pleasing to you know the goddess of reason or whatever yeah so confusing times for a young lad the whole thing aboutorsica is so chaotic and anarchic. So by 1790, he's still there. They've sent a letter. He has actually composed a letter that ends up being read out
in the French National Assembly, which is effectively asking for Corsica to be fully integrated into the French nation. Which is weird, isn't it? Because he's writing that at the same time as he's writing his,
you know, genocidal fantasy about killing Frenchmen. As you said, it's so confused and chaotic. He gets his brother elected to the General Assembly in Corsica, and they're sort of having gang fights with other Corsicans. Then this guy, Pasquale Paoli, he makes a triumphant return to Corsica in the summer of 1790. Napoleon makes sure he's there in Ajaccio to welcome him. He's in the crowds. He and his brother Joseph and all their friends and some of the other brothers,
they're part of patriotic clubs in Ajaccio. They're giving speeches. He's kind of roistering around the streets, having fights. He's also engaging in class warfare, isn't he? Because he writes a letter at Butterfucko. Right. You did that with far too much relish, and I think that the listeners will see through you. No, not at all. Not at all. Butterfucko, of course, is the representative of the nobility. And by this point in 1790, the revolution in Paris is gaining speed. And so that element of class warfare is spreading to Corsica. And the Corsicans seem rarely to need any incentive to engage in fractious street fighting. But now they have a kind of additional motive. So it really is kind of chaos. It spends 1791, 1792, endlessly going back to France and back to Corsica.
Well, because he's still in the army, right? He's still in the army and he can't stay away for too long because basically he'll be a deserter. A deserter. And as the pressure rises within France, especially when the war breaks out with France's neighbours, he won't just be a deserter, he will be a traitor. So there's that beginning to hang over him. Yeah, because all the other officers have literally fled abroad and are starting to
make common cause with France's enemies in an attempt to restore the monarchy. Yeah. So June 1791, the key moments in the revolution. We'll be coming back to the French Revolution, hopefully the middle of next year, won't we, Tom? To mark the Paris Olympics, I think there'd be nothing more fun than doing a whole series about the worst excesses of the terror. So this key moment, the king, Louis XVI,
decides he's going to try and flee the country, get out of France, it's all gone wrong. And he is intercepted at Varennes, near the border with the Austrian Netherlands, now Belgium, and he is brought back. And that's a moment when the paranoia of the revolution, the sense of kind of incipient looming violence,
really ratchets up. And at this point, the stakes are getting higher and higher. So a false move from Napoleon, if he allies himself with the wrong faction, things, of course, can completely spill out of control. He was no longer just a teenager playing at politics. could lose his life if if things don't work out and actually after multiple trips he's back in ajaxio in april 1792 and there are lots of murders going on there is fighting he ends up in a sort of massive brawl in the streets and pasquale paoli who's been
very fond of him up to this point, because he's seen him as a fan, basically, starts to kind of wash his hands with the Bonapartes and thinks that whole family are much more trouble than they're worth. This is what happens, he says, when inexperienced little boys are placed in command of the National Guards. So at that point, about 1792, I would say, Napoleon's position in Corsica, where he had fancied himself as one of Pasquale Paolo's kind of nationalist coming men, is actually beginning to slip out of control. He's losing traction in Corsica is very unamused by Napoleon's activities and actually
writes to the war ministry in Paris saying, essentially, that he's a traitor, that he should be dismissed. This is very alarming for Napoleon. When he, in the summer of 1792, goes back to Paris, he has that kind of hanging over him, the worry about what people in the war ministry are going to be making of this. But fortunately, he arrives in Paris, goes to the war ministry, and discovers that it's absolute chaos there as well. And that if the letters arrive, certainly no one has read it. The letter says, that whole family, the family has no merit other than spying, treachery, vice, impudence, and prostitution, which is a harsh thing to say about somebody's family but as you say yeah the woman's just in chaos because france is suddenly at war
with its neighbors and he is actually on the 20th of june 1792 very french behaviors met up with a friend for lunch for a long lunch at a local brasserie and when they come out they see this huge crowd descending on the tuileries on the palace. This is the moment when the crowd, this mob, forces the king, who's basically now a prisoner under palace arrest, to put on the red cap of liberty. Napoleon sees this. It's really interesting because you said he was a Republican. He is a Republican, but he's also always an autocrat. He's a believer in strong, ruthless government, I think.
Well, he believes in order, doesn't he? He does believe in order because he says- Because he's a believer in strong, ruthless government, I think. Well, he believes in order, doesn't he? He does believe in order. Because he's a military man. So, I mean, his whole education has instilled that in him. And he says of the king, and it's so interesting that he says this in Italian, not in French. He says, Che coglioni! What a jerk.
What a fool to be so weak as to be forced by the mob to put on this kind of red cap. And then almost two months later, Napoleon, he's at his lodgings, and he hears the sound of the tocsin ringing. And he comes down to the street, and he sees this huge mob rampage down the street with the head of a man on a pike. And they're shouting, vive la nation, vive la nation. And actually, what has happened is the mob has attacked the Tuileries Palace. They have forced the king and his family to flee to the assembly for safety,
and they have butchered all the defenders of the palace. And Napoleon, who despises the king, walks through the palace afterwards, the gardens, and the gardens are strewn with dead bodies of the Swiss guards and the nobles who were trying to defend the king. And there are still people there, as one of the historiographers says, finishing off the wounded and mutilating their bodies in obscene ways. And Napoleon is horrified by this. But what horrifies him is not so much the violence as the disorder, isn't it, Tom? This sort of anarchy, which he dreads.
I saw even quite well-dressed women commit the most extreme indecencies on the bodies of the Swiss guard. So you can imagine what they're doing. And you're right that this in no way is an expression of sympathy for the king. And when the mob corner him and demand that he cries, vive la nation, he says, well, I did this very happily. Of course I did. But I think it's, as you say, it's contempt for the mob, the canaille, he despises it because you have to have order and discipline. So he's an authoritarian Jacobin. It's quite a recognizable type. He's very, very definitely a Robespierreist. I mean, he is definitely on the far left of the revolutionary movement, but at the same time, he's very, very authoritarian
and thinks there needs to be discipline and structure and control. And it's about this point, would you say, so the Corsican-ness is beginning to, it never fades completely. He's still always Corsican, but he's no longer trumpeting it as he did before because he's perhaps found a new cause. Do you think that's? I think he has, yeah. I think he has in the revolution at this point.
Yeah. Presumably, at the back of his mind, and this will become very evident in part two when we look at what happens over the next few years, he must be aware of the fact that the clearing away of so many aristocrats from the army has opened up a lot of space for a young man on the make like himself. Yeah. And that if only he can prove his value to the French Republic, you know, there is great scope for very, very rapid promotion of a kind that there simply wouldn't have been
10 years before. Well, that seems like the perfect point on which to bring this episode to a close, Tom. So we have this young man. What is he? 24, 25? Not even that. Who is driven, ambitious, very prickly, spiky. Pretty humorless.
Very humorless. I mean, there's no trace of humor whatsoever. Spends his time writing these gothic vampire novels or whatever it is. He's writing his history of Corsica. Tom, the parallels are absolutely extraordinary, aren't they? Well. Man of destiny. If circumstances had been different, who knows where I might be.
Exactly. On an island in the Atlantic. I will say this. Sometimes I do tease you on this podcast, but you have a very lively sense of humour. I think it is fair to say. You're too kind, Dominic. As was evidenced by that excellent reading
at the beginning of the episode, which I think a lot of people will want to immediately go back and listen to again because they enjoyed it so much. Well, so we will have another reading in our next episode. You're spoiling us. Which will be coming out on Thursday.
But if you want to hear the next reading, which will be done in a different accent, so making a kind of intriguing biographical point, you could, if you wanted to join the Restless History Club,
you could hear it straight away. if not we will see you on thursday for the next installment of our special on young napoleon so we will see you then bye-bye au revoir i'm marina hyde and i'm richard osmond and together we host the rest is entertainment I'm Marina Hyde and I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news
reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club
if you want ad free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.